[Music]
go check this out
one two three
the best
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one
hello
everyone hello
hello happy tuesday happy lost judgment
day
for those of you who
have the judgment has been found we
found our last judgment uh this is
available
today for people who is it what you
pre-ordered the digital deluxe version
is that what it is ultimate and there's
also a digital deluxe and i think both
of them give you access if as long as
it's not the base version yes base
version is available for everyone for
friday uh but we're here with the game
we're gonna be playing some this is
spoiler free by the way uh for those of
you worried about that we're not gonna
be talking about anything with the plot
we're just gonna be showing off some fun
side stuff some mini games we're gonna
be having a good time
uh i'm gonna be playing
i am playing with a slight
lag
so i'm i'm a little nervous about it uh
for some of the minigames we'll just get
right into it uh
we can trust you with your your
your spoiler knowledge because you've
you've gotten how far in the game so far
like chapter
uh oh i'm all the way up on chapter nine
uh is where i'm at i'm not done yet i'm
almost done i think so you know you know
what's good and what's
safe and what isn't exactly and the
point i made sure my save is all like
spoiler spoiler free so yeah let's
let's do that little fancy transition
there smooth as heck yeah thank you
so right now uh i'm actually in chapter
four right now because
there is a
side mission in camarocho
that i really wanted to do i wanted to
start the stream off at this side
mission because i
yeah uh
okay so here we go i'm gonna go over
here
now did you stumble upon this quest by
accident like how did you how did you
discover this it's uh it's just right
here on the map so that's the nice thing
is is there's like multiple ways to find
side quests in this game but uh a lot of
them they'll pop up on the map
uh if you go to the the yagami uh if you
go to this detective agency on the board
they have like the special ones on the
board from like the previous judgment uh
they also have the um
the the chatter
system
as well that you can use uh ufo
ufo yep uh here's yakimi he's
skateboarding badly somebody cool yeah
well there's so many people in the way
what are you gonna do
yeah
yeah give me first skater
oh
i think i have to beat these guys up
first you gotta
have some fights first yeah you always
gotta warm with a good a good puncher
yeah there's always people who want to
beat you up for some reason
uh i actually really enjoy the fighting
in this game
uh a bit more than the original
on me too i like it quite a bit there's
something a little bit off about how
some of the
what's that like some of the animations
in the first game had dog me like
maybe moving around too much
i definitely uh felt an immediate
like it just felt better when i started
playing it for sure
i also think it's really it's really
nice to go back to like traditional
yakuza combat after playing like a
dragon i love like a dragon's turn base
but uh it was like oh i missed this a
little bit let's just be able to beat
the [ __ ] out of people
yeah
give me my money
i don't have the code open the register
just a part-timer are you are we
assigning voices for these
i feel like that might be a good thing
okay all right ben your your scared
voice
okay i'm i'm scared voice i got it evan
your angry
voice i don't give a [ __ ] what you are
open it or you're dead
what the is that a robbery
people are annoyed by this we can we can
stop but
i know some people like that
and cuts it's the last shot for the day
thank you everyone
tomorrow morning we'll pick things up
back at the studio
extras you'll be getting an email from
us soon thanks again
oh man they were shooting office alone
four here i wish i could have snuck in
among the extras
[Laughter]
you know i i really thought they kind of
went off the rails in office alone three
um
they recast the main character it's just
uh
it it kind of
it's not as good
i completely agree all went downhill
jump the shark according to chatter
they're shooting a robbery scene at
another location too
are movies with robbery is that popular
i feel like there's so many characters
now are like yeah yeah this is uh
normally there's not this many
i miss i miss the spirit voice where'd
they go
oh it's for a movie jeez i was really
worried there for a sec
guess i should beat it i don't want to
get in the way of cleanup
but what if you get involved in a wacky
scenario so they mentioned i'm gonna say
hey uh on chatter they have a thing
about another
movie so we're like okay absolutely
they're also filming it over here
so now we can go
head over this way
that's cool that they use chattering
that way in this game or like
yeah
there's slowly
but yeah
oh
i think it's uh my
did i do this right
you have to like go around the block
real quick
i thought it was right here
oh wait i see that i see the icon now
now it's there well there i think i
think i had to click the the robbery one
specifically
yeah but that is really cool that like
they use chatter in that way now because
i remember that was in the first game
with uh i think supermodel where it's
just like oh you could use it for like
very specific things but now i can like
help you find quests i think that's
really cool
all right angry voice is back
oh i'm sorry that's me i think
give me the goddamn money move it
i i i don't have the code to open the
register
i'm just a part-timer wait hold on this
is my line again
i don't give a [ __ ] what you are open it
or you're dead
what the is that a robbery
come on but weren't they shooting the
same scene before and they said they
were done
what's this temporary clothes due to
filming
something doesn't add up
they were done shooting in that cafe on
uh tenkaichi
street why would anyone bother shooting
identical scenes at different locations
something's weird here i'll see any
staff around this is fishy
i should observe the storefront for a
bit
so another change they made is you can
just like investigate and like pull up
your stuff at any point which is kind of
cool
um
yeah i like i like that change a little
bit i like that
i can't say i've ever seen alps trying
to use one of these signs before
all right
it's got a little sos on there
it's real subtle
uh
wait are they actually saying there's a
robbery right now
i hope i'm just worried over nothing but
if i'm right about this there's a real
problem
i should check out the situation for
myself maybe i'll loop around in the
back of the store and pop in quietly
this can only go well
[Laughter]
damn it's locked
well this is an emergency
ooh block picking yep lock picking mini
game
i like the lock picking in
in judgment a lot
makes sense yeah
there's a i think there's like that one
side mission where you could become like
a locksmith in the first game which is
kind of fun too um yes yes i do remember
that
all right evan this is you
oh [ __ ] oh i'm burglary
or you're dead hear me
no please don't do this i can't open it
i really can't
i knew it that sign was saying there's a
robbery right now not a film shoot
i gotta call the cops
this is going nowhere [ __ ] it
that'll be female
now give me the money or this lady's
dying right in front of you
[ __ ]
this is bad no time for cops i've got to
do something
what can i do without getting anyone
hurt how can i close the distance
all right hear the door
shut
it is
an onomicio outfit
for promotional use in the onomicho
collaboration menu kickoff event guess
that explains why it's here
could this help me get close to the
burglar
yeah put it on
put on the onomichio outfit
well i guess you wouldn't expect
onomicho to charge on him maybe i
actually could take him by surprise
can i though this is starting to seem a
little out there
do i really want to take on this burglar
as onumichio absolutely
you know what if i could find the right
spot i could all right pal
time to meet you maker
yeah
yes i'm doing the pose
what
yes the wide shot it's perfect
did i see
now why would i see a giant
orange-headed dude standing there wait
where are you what
so that's not the right thing you're
supposed to do
no that [ __ ]
is actually the right thing
so
this may not be the right thing to do
but the other option wait a minute there
are a whole bunch of boxes here
so many boxes guess they could get
tossed back here aren't they supposed to
flatten them this one's pretty big
though maybe i could get in and sneak in
on them real slick like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're also a good option
center gravity's pretty low feel like i
can manage though if i don't make any
wrong moves all right
time for some tactical cafe action
action
yeah
this is why okay
okay
you want to watch this woman died
by the way i am moving the box
someone please
like when he's not looking yeah but he's
not looking gifted
i was gonna say was that box say uh
oh boy yes it does
because the agave's in there
what's wrong
did i [ __ ] up
oh i messed up
i didn't do this last time i made it
last time
oh [ __ ] yoga me
whoa what did
okay i guess i can still finish it
anyway but
i managed to properly sync up on him the
first time i did it
okay yeah now we can beat up the
unsavory man look at how low he got he's
got a powerful stance
oh yeah look at yagami
that's why i saw that and i was like i
have to i have to play this on the
stream for ben this is very important
that was like not only did it have
odometrio but it had metal gear salad i
mean that's yeah that's amazing
i will say um
i think this is
i think the story of this game is uh
kind of mixed in my opinion it's maybe
the most um
i still enjoy it but i think it's maybe
the most mixed i felt on a on a rgg
story
the side quests however i think are some
of the best
i think i think they're side stuff
uh
that woman was in on it
um oh man
yeah i think their side stuff their mini
games uh some of the writing some of the
humor it's it's
it's some of their best work it's really
really good so if you're into that stuff
like you're gonna have a fantastic time
with this one
cool that sounds great
all right guys get ready to
chase them down
i will say if you did not if you did not
like this minigame uh there is a lot of
it in this one so
that has not changed
it was the new thing in four and they're
like we've got a cool cop character that
lets you chase down people
and that was like the whole thing
yeah they did a lot in uh
before i remember
oh man so i'm like whiffing this real
bad
oh you're good you got a little bit of
input leg
yeah yeah it's definitely yes it's the
input lag of course
uh i thought it was cool and like the
first one in this game when like yogurt
like jumped on the truck and like ran
across the truck yeah like he doesn't
he does that a couple times too
but it also like slows them down so it's
like the first thing i think you're
about to do it yeah yeah but you're also
i feel like it slows you down a little
bit when you do that so like they get
farther away
like well that's cool but i don't know
all right well i've like way way way
with this one but i'll i'll still catch
up to him eventually i'm all i'm
surprised that they didn't give me the
option like oh you've got the skateboard
now escape
got a skateboard after him
me too
like a way to kind of just upgrade the
idea of the chase mechanic
maybe
instead of doing sweet wall runs you do
sweet wall rides
yeah that would really be a
geography pro skater
uh it does have an old sonic game it's
got a sonic the fighters in here uh
oh we'll go to the arcade don't worry
we'll make sure to hit all that up
uh i i knew that the game looked
familiar i guess it was in the sonic
gems collection on gamecube which i
remember playing and i was like oh yeah
i was like i have played this game
before
got him
how's the chat doing
they were they were freaking out you
know onomichio metal gear solid
good
it's a heck of a time we're here to
please there's some real
man
there's some real good ones
uh you help out a game developer at one
point
which is exactly
has the exact bits you'd expect uh
perfect perfect there's a there's an
evil detective that yagami has to track
down
uh
who who like he runs the illegal
detective agency
oh illegally illegal
they call the illegal a detective agency
but he's just giving people things to do
crimes there's no detectiving he's doing
oh this is his detective name there's no
detecting he's not a detective at all i
don't know why he's called the detective
he's he's just
i think he calls himself a detective and
yagami's like this guy's giving
detectives a bad name i gotta take him
down
also sorry i'm i'm skipping through all
this dialogue uh oh no you're good
they're working together they take
advantage of the different local events
to commit crimes raising much attention
ah so this time they exploited a movie
shoot nearby
but it wasn't enough to keep him out of
the clink thanks again oh and the owner
of alps asked me to give you this
extra recipe
even though you destroyed all of his
furniture in an attempt to beat the
regular fine
i got that perk that lets me still shop
at uh places even after i destroy him so
i'm gonna go
quite the opposite actually he said he
couldn't wait to open uh doors back up
again once we're done with the scene
wow really
well i guess that's just alps for you
you've been armed robberies enough to
shake them down
or shake them
history
they've been in every yakuza game that's
like one of the staples
i suppose i better get going businesses
that have been around the longest and
yakuza dude i would make that video if i
knew it would do well i would make it
you know it would let us know
promise us you'll watch it if john luke
makes it
are you interested in the history of
kamurocho we've got a video dude i'll
talk about the takoyaki stand that got
replaced with the gelato stand that now
is replaced with nothing
oh it's back to nothing again
real estate prices
evan you want to take excited youth
oh sure hey did you see that office
alone for league there's this burglary
in a cafe it's so sick
hugs weren't they just shooting that
though
how's it already out
i guess someone secretly filled it with
their phone while they were on set
seriously have to see it like it's so
real
oh no
oh no
that's also a footage of like if you do
it right
which i did not
oh what
this angry guy catching the robber is he
the main character can't really see his
face from this angle or maybe he's
standing right next to me
any idea who he is i don't recognize him
maybe this is his first movie he's good
at action though if he's got acting
chops he might even have a decent career
i'll show you chops
maybe i'll poke my head into the drama
club one of these days though
oh that's a good side quest finish it is
oh some of the music well we'll get into
that okay so why don't we now
uh
head back to the title so i can load in
a later save in yokohama
and we can do some
sign stuff
nice i'm into it i'm excited i haven't
had a chance to delve into the side
stuff like
i like this title screen a lot too the
style screen's really good uh you got
yoga over there if you go down to the
game settings
see that cat
it's a good cat
and the music's really good too i wonder
if
this scene has some significance in the
story i don't know about yet but we'll
find out eventually
me too yeah i haven't i haven't come
across anything it might just be like a
moo a mood setter shock me is all things
are serious now
all right guys so here we are we're in
yokohama um
and
we can do whatever we want what do
people want to start with do we want to
start with some arcade stuff
do we want to start with some school
stuff
what's the challenge
yeah what's the what's chat feeling
chaffian what are you guys feeling
i might say arcade stuff because people
were already asking about it earlier
it's a good call yeah why don't we go uh
okay let's uh let's take the taxi to
i think
the arcade is
benjamin asks if it's anything like
sleeping dogs it's like sleeping dogs
but
but a bit a bit better i love sleeping i
love sleeping dogs too
uh
less car driving
oh there it is more
running and skateboarding or
skateboarding
yeah it's like sleeping dogs if uh if
you had a skateboard
and you could go to an arcade
uh
and play sonic the fighters
and you could beat a high school kid
all right
someone is asking is this a playstation
exclusive it is not it is also on xbox
one and series x and s but it's not on
pp unfortunately no pc sadly so uh
uh we got some good oh uh
the crane games if i can uh
hopefully
see here they have onomichio statues
oh yeah
and they have uh what's his name the uh
camarocho mascot from like a dragon as
well
uh i think that's become more prominent
like they show it like right at the
beginning of this game
the kamurocho mascot
i appreciate they're trying to make that
a thing and if i can uh i think i got it
observation mode
uh they have fake onomichio
oh
the knockoff they have knockoff odometeo
which i love i think that's so good uh
all right
so uh they not only do they have sonic
the fighters they actually have a bunch
of really good obscure um they got
fighting vipers they got fighting vipers
they've got um motor raid
they got some good stuff so
let me just start off here follow up to
that uh the house the dead back up yes
we will we will do that one as well
heck yeah
nice you decide between this and uh
both great games from my understanding
i uh i have i love rgg games so i'd say
lost judgment but i would also recommend
playing first judgment if you haven't
before
i think the first judgment is
uh got the superior introduction we were
kind of talking about that before we
started um i think this this game has a
weak start and i think the first game
has a better setup um
i also think overall um
like i love yagami and all the
characters in kaito but um
they they kind of have less personal
stakes in this in the the main plot of
this one versus the first one uh it
feels a little more personal to them so
i think it's kind of a stronger
a stronger main story overall so i would
recommend definitely playing the first
one
um
all right let's go
who are we playing
uh
knuckles
all right
i'm like sonic he does not chuckle he'd
rather flex his muscles
it's true by the way i don't understand
how this game works at all
people who play this game understand how
this game works
it's uh
it's not
it's not great
no
i will say i actually like the way it
looks like the the
the kind of early polygon stuff kind of
holds up like the art style is
surprisingly uh
you know it's really colorful it looks
good so i don't know what i'm doing i'm
most perfect my clone yeah what are you
talking about baby you're amazing
i'm looking forward to people
you should yeah i'd support you um i'm
looking forward to people tuning into
this stream and being like i thought
they're playing lost judgment why are
they very funny
one thing that's so cool about the
arcade stuff of these games is um i
think a lot of them are done by um
m2 which is like a
japanese developer that specializes in
like sporting games they they did like
they helped uh segue with like the ages
collection um so they do like really
really good like arcades of the game so
all the arcade ports and the yakuza
games are like
fan [ __ ] tastic
nice
dancing
i also like that they have more context
than this one and that you got that
esports club
yes there's an esports club uh the
esports club is one of my favorite uh
because the dialogue is is so funny
um
you're hanging out with a bunch of uh
capital g gamers
oh see amy's a lot tougher
here yeah this is the wow that's a huge
difficulty spike all of a sudden
can i can i give a uh
maybe it's controversial i don't know i
like amy's original design better than
her modern design
this one yeah this is the
red dress
yeah her like red pink dress
i like her uh her songs
designed better i think she looks cooler
yeah i can totally be honest
i didn't even know amy had like a
previous design like pre-sonic adventure
but that's on me
i mean that's fair
chad's all the way across the stage with
that one
the uh the stretchy cartoon bits wow
it's pretty good
just dead fell off the flying stage
knuckles is real happy with himself for
that one
i like that you're collecting all the
chaos emeralds
as you beat each
uh everyone's favorite sonic the
hedgehog not original character bart
yeah dude woof mark mark on this guy
who could forget
bark
yeah you know like when you beat sonic
adventure all the characters and super
sound killing loft the bark storyline
the bark story where was bark during all
this
what was bark up to like in station
square
i would i would play an expansion on
that i may do it
yeah if they do a song adventure remake
they'll have hopefully they'll have bark
the sonic adventure 3 is just going to
be all bark
someone asked how many different games
are there in the sega arcades this time
around
uh quite a bit so
uh the other arcade uh
up in chinatown which we'll go to has
like completely different games
uh so there's a fair amount of them
that's where the
the house the dead thing probably is
right
uh maybe we'll move on from this i don't
know if i wanted yeah we don't need to
get all the chaos emeralds
here that's cool
it's actually really rare that they got
this inside of here uh into it
uh and i'm gonna pick cause i like
playing bonj because he's just he's just
it's just general
the ko
corral man uh sega's got a lot of uh
great fighting
properties they could really
bring back you know oh
ass handed to me though this one i
definitely don't know how to
i play in you believe in the leaving the
heart of the cards believe in friendship
thank you
yeah it said rattlesnake burger
oh wonderful
that seems real i don't i would not eat
that
i think about it but then i probably
chickened out
i just it but not even like the venom
thing it just seems would that be real
gaming that just wouldn't taste very
good
i do like burgers maybe my
yeah they could you know like if they
cut it with like some ground beef maybe
that might also not work though i think
we have a bigger problem flipping behind
it there's like a cow patty ice cream
okay well well that that's just uh
that's just a trick that's that's a scam
don't fall for that one
uh someone in the chat wants to know do
you know if the damn puyo puyo is back
can i jump into this game if i haven't
played the first one no uh i think we
would all recommend playing the first
judgment yeah if you have not we're
jumping into lost
i would say like you you technically can
if you want like the it doesn't spoil
the story i think it does an okay job
setting up the characters
but
i would recommend playing the first yeah
i think
i think the first game is the
better game overall um and they recently
really re-released it on ps5 and xbox uh
and uh it's it's a good it's a good
version of that game
judgment is one um the best stories they
have done
i like it a lot yeah i agree
i think this story is a little more
hit or miss
uh yeah the first judgment i think also
like
there's like a whole conspiracy that
unfolds and it's just like it's way more
interesting as it goes on yeah um the
conspiracy of this one is
[ __ ] wild let me tell you it go it gets
real crazy real quick
uh evan you're about to get to the point
where it gets like
nutso
what are you watching we're playing
fighting vipers in lost judgment
uh we've got errol in the twitch chat
saying what up time boys
this kid with their skateboard
i think they're on top of it
uh what's the title of this arcade sorry
i didn't catch it what is the title i
don't actually remember uh fighting
viper
fighting viper
oh which i lost
on the wall
all right
oh yeah it's right there
right there we go
all right all right i quit out there
got some
special points uh this fantasy zone
which i think they've had before i'm
terrible at fantasy zones so i might
skip that one
which
i had also never heard of uh
but is is it's really cool
oh you know that's a real animated
the logo 3d yeah
they're really pulling from some like
late 90s early 2000s era sega arcades uh
that i think like most people don't
remember and i'm i'm here for it
uh someone says i thought this was lost
judgment and it's clickbait you're
absolutely correct we baited you all
we're just playing old sega arcade games
can we appreciate how these uh
like the transition they morph and it
makes a slurping sound
when i see my polygons morph i think of
slurping
yeah
i mean
oh look at this that's a nice jpeg
you got this
i love this hellscape world like red
fiery sky
yeah
it's actually kind of red they got one
of these these
3d racers in there
[Music]
yeah there you go
it's like f-zero and road rage just just
kind of smashed together i'd love to see
it
yeah
a little bit of a little bit of episode
one pod racer in there
yeah
now this is fire racing
how are all three playing we're not all
three playing uh
we're just
we all love these games
i i specifically got into these games
because of these two guys here on top of
uh michael hym
love you michael
um
it was it was quarantined and i was like
you know everyone's saying yeah cause
it's so great i was like well i guess
it's time to start yakuza and here i am
eight nine games
about it
people eventually play it
they're good i'll admit that they're
good
they're real damn good
they're really really
all good we'll uh we'll cut out this one
as well but uh this is another fun one
it's it's cool that they uh
they put this in here
i'll even have a button configuration in
there so you can change the
stuff around
all right why don't we then head over to
the other arcade
on your skateboard my skateboard
oh i missed that little
are you in fact rolling around at the
speed of sound
oh
uh not yet but you know what
there's some other mini games
that could maybe uh we can maybe make
that happen
i mean i got places to go gotta follow
my way forward at the right layer
uh really nailed it but you're close
okay all right cool
[ __ ] tricks
yeah
hey yoga be doing kick flip
okay
oh jeez
oh that was a good save
i like these uh these points that you
can pick up
yeah
there's no reason to do this other than
just like
yagami showing off his sick skills you
know
what's the problem
skateboarding
about
punching stuff
it's interesting like i know this
happens in every rgg game but it's like
that building on the left i was like
that was important and like a dragon
yeah yeah yeah and you're like oh now
it's not and you know like
uh i love that about it like it always
feels like this evolving town you're
like oh there's ichiban holdings right
up there you cannot go on holdings it
was the first thing i tried
you said one of the person
was like oh there's yakimi's
office
because you can't you cannot do it
well i i saw like
i tried to go in like gender law office
and like a dragon and i couldn't i
didn't see any signage for it i was like
but doesn't it take place between
all the judgments like where is it
yeah
all right
here we go the other sega by the way sad
news uh the um
one of the last big major sega arcades
shut down today yeah it's all the people
turning out to send it off so now uh now
they exist only here in the virtual
space
see that's another reason number 10
million and five why yakuza is a great
video game because it immortalizes sega
arcades in japan
i i appreciate they they actually have
our opponents
they have house of the dead they'll have
like you know
like uh wonderland wars they'll have
real arcade games that are you actually
can find at those arcades
um
so there's a isuzuzaki road
hum of the dead
uh they also got
super hang on
space harrier those are all uh holdouts
from the old ones
virtual fighter 5
uh but we're here
we're here for holla the dead
this is the closest thing i'll get to my
uh
uh dead souls kiwami and
it's it's a good time but like you know
i still want dead souls kiwami
i would rather that over kiwami three i
feel like you don't really three
remastered exist
yeah
yeah
i'm curious what it'd be like
yeah i'd love to be orphanage geary dad
again but now in kiwami style
give me give me that dragon engine uh
version of this shirt
yeah
and uh
him chopping food for the kids yeah yeah
yeah
just angrily cutting up an onion
yeah
i really wish there was an actual way to
like hook up a light gun and play this
game
yeah like do not if you're not like if
you're not one of like ps4 you could try
to like
somehow
there are but like i don't
unless like they input it properly like
the best you'd have to get is um
like a pc mod but these are only in the
judgment games uh which
are non-pc
i'm actually surprised that we don't
have like
a gyroscope things like before
yeah right
at least
oh yeah that's interesting
because this ps5 has gyro right or is
that just sweet no it does
okay yeah
they have to be there has to be like
like a dead souls or something why would
they bring all these models up to be
like this
just give give it to me
i mean uh if you played the original uh
camera of the dead one
like they just straight up were using
the old uh dead souls like version of
kamurocho and you can tell like the
quality of everything looked
way down
look at how look at how high fidelity
and
slippery that monster was yeah and i
don't i don't get it because i've
already played it before but uh you get
your little like in-game achievement and
it does say uh dead souls
for playing it oh like the trophy or
yeah yeah
well like the little in-game like
achievement um that you get on
tom rogo or whatever yeah yeah yeah yeah
comro go yeah i think it's called the
same thing i think it's just called town
go in this one
oh yeah well i guess it's both right
yeah
[Applause]
there's like a
there you go
well i was gonna say like the only
reason i didn't platinum the first
judgment is because you had 100 complete
that comro go thing i was like
no
uh
i am of the opinion that you should
never try and platinum any yakuza game
because it'll make you hate that game
i actually i did yakuza 6 which i think
is the only one worth doing because the
requirements for that one are
really easy they really tone it down for
yakuza you really only have to like beat
all the side quests because there's
actually an exploit specifically in
yakuza 6 where you can reload a save
with the final boss change it to legend
beat it and you'll get the trophy for
beating it on legendary difficulties
and then the rest of it it's you don't
have 100 complete yakuza 6 you don't
have to do
ever you just have to basically beat all
the side games and there's like a few
other misleading stuff it's actually
really
it's somewhat easy to do yeah none of
the other ones don't don't do any of the
other ones um
uh ray
who used to work at achievement hunter
um he like has really gotten into the
yakuza games lately and he like plays
them all and uh he also like
loves like platinuming or i guess not
plating 100 percenting the achievements
on xbox and he recently did it for five
and said it was like the most miserable
experience of his life
the game and i was like
no
don't do that to yourself dude
i could see it for five months
especially
five is huge there's so much to five
like the time it takes to beat the main
story of five is how long it took to
just get the platinum in six like that's
how long five main story alone is
yeah for real
uh
virtual fighter five isn't the new one
they re-released it's like no
it's the original arcade one um i was
curious about that myself but yeah it's
just the original version
um yeah town go
yeah has like yeah there's
oh this is this is all the school stuff
here there is some
there's a lot more than i thought there
was there's only yeah i was gonna say
there are 10
10 different sub stories you can do
there
wow it is it is a lot
uh
at the arcade yeah dead souls
i love it a lot of good a lot of good
jokes in here oh my favorite is um
the photography club
what oh no
i almost is the next what's the next one
is it every
oh man we gotta find out
uh why don't we go do
why don't we go to the skate park
yeah rolling around at the speed of
round
yeah i i think it's neat that they uh
like even though we aren't getting like
the house of the dead games although
we're getting out like a remake yeah we
are getting a remake of one
yeah
they're still like
let's make some uh
just house of the dead thing and put it
in another game
oh
god yo
you knew what was up
like that's yagami i've seen all this
fighting technique
i'll never expect my missile drop kick
i love the move uh when someone's
holding a weapon and you can like disarm
them from it in this game where it's
like you start the button a couple times
oh
that's like his one good move he's like
i'm just gonna keep spamming this move
that's what i would do
destroyed one thing that i like that
they do is uh at the end of every battle
so you get bonus sp based on stuff you
do so they encourage you to like
go through and like do multiple things
uh for each battle to get little bonus
xp
which i think is interesting yeah
because i'm assuming like
all that's all the upgrades and stuff
still cost like a ton of sps oh yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah that stuff's all like
we got 20 000
yeah that costs a lot um
in fact why don't we uh
nope i don't even have the money for
that one never mind
anyway this is this is uh my crew of
skateboarding kids that i hang out with
uh
heck yeah whole crew
i've already finished their storyline
but uh i can still hang out with them so
we can go to the park
the combo park the section jam
take my skateboard yeah you can buy
skateboards
was that the mlg horn
[Music]
uh
i love the spray paint behind like the
words great and excellent yeah it's
really good
i was like how there was just like one
cut scene in the original judgment where
he used a skateboard and now it's just a
like yeah they're like yeah skateboards
that's his thing he does it
well i mean think about it he could also
dance all of a sudden in this game like
the dancing one is particularly funny
because they uh they established that he
doesn't know how to dance and he's like
but i do know kung fu and they're like
that's like dancing you should dance and
then he just does this like perfectly
choreographed dance
that's our detective
[Music]
uh i think this game has one of their
better soundtracks it is uh
eclectic
there's so much style and variety but i
think they nail
they nail all of it hey i got my appeal
up that means i can do more of the um
the the uh
dancing mini game
uh there's also a race i could do as
well
oh look at like a downhill jam
yeah
ooh you've got a lot more skateboards
yeah you get like
doing these gets you points that you
just use at the skate shop uh with these
guys
now is the skateboard automatically on
during these because i've been having
issues with my
yes
yes
okay it's automatically on for for these
mini games so you will be fine
like mario kart power-ups
ooh can you like throw banana peels at
people yeah yeah yeah you throw popcorn
and
all right
like be the adult here and like not try
to like be the winner you know
he's here to beat them
he's got something to prove
i guess being a lawyer and detective
wasn't
the enough really doing it for me i'm
still thinking about it
uh someone asked is this more grinding
than the first judgment the xp required
to unlock attributes seem very high
uh
i feel like it's on par
um maybe hopefully a little less but at
least in my opinion like i've never
found the um
like it was necessary in order to
uh second place uh
like you could kind of i guess if your
goal is to try and 100 everything like
get all the skills yeah it'll probably
be pretty grindy but you can get plenty
to just get through the game and and
have a good time
um
that music while you're racing uh
had like a brief jet set flashback
and that was real neat all right i gotta
say my money i gotta save my my skate
points get the purple drop
um
[Music]
all right what a cool bunch of kids i
know
let's uh let's keep going so we got um
well first off
nope
oh we're all messing up
those kids were like hey that guy
doesn't know how to skateboard
let's beat him up
but yagami doesn't have to fight
i
feel bad because as soon as you were
asking that question if it was too
grindy i was like hell yeah it's grindy
look at these these these big crimes
i realize you were asking a legitimate
question
because yeah giving skills seem to take
a while
i wish that i could see the skateboard
integrated more into everything yagami
does i want him to do like skateboard
fight attacks
uh yeah they're you know what
is there
why they're like skateboard
like i want him to like initiate a fight
with a bunch of bad guys by like i don't
know like flipping off of his board and
like tossing the board at the people or
something i don't see anything
i'll be real
skateboarding and fighting
all right might not have the play pass
for it but let's see if we can do the uh
paradise vr
that's returned in this one
i really enjoy uh the vr stuff
yeah that like mario party set up
and you get to shoot like energy balls
out of your hands
it's real like token type nonsense
do a short course oh i don't have enough
ah
how do you get play passes uh you have
to like buy them and stuff from from
shops uh i can do this little mini game
i unlocked though
that's just
this weird
uh twin stick shooter
i just got this from doing a side quest
he just jumped inside of his
okay yeah yeah no i'm in i'm down fizz
i've completed over 300
vr
this is actually really sick i don't
even know what this is here no be either
like i think
more so than any other previous rgg game
i think like almost all the mini games
just like hit really good for me
uh like there are you know like
sometimes you you play a mini game and
you're like
i never want to play that one again that
one sucks um i won't say they're all
perfect but like they're way more hits
or misses than this one i think they're
all really well done
the like
the cut-ins of yagami like
yeah
it was really good
this could have just been like a like a
sloppy
half run together thing
no they've got the voxel bits in it
they've got the cuttings
it's got its own ui
it's got challenges
yeah this is amazing
and this isn't even like one of the main
ones like i said i got it just from
doing a side quest
i'm into it this is cool
oh
nice
there we go
anyway so that's cool um
maybe i'll maybe i'll try and find a
play pass later but uh items that are
picked up in the game are just for
crafting or for selling
uh you you craft things with them i'm
pretty sure there's multiple uh
mini games that involve crafting stuff
there you go
uh there so there is drones they they
have drone building there's the the
drone racing again we can go check that
out if you want
um
there is also a robot fighting
oh yeah in this one
which is real good so why don't we you
know what let's head to the stuff let's
head to the school
let's go back to school
let's go take a test
we gotta head to school because we gotta
all right
it's a little weird that yoga just gets
to kind of run around uh a school and
hang out with these kids but you know
what um
he's wearing his
his low-cut t-shirt and his tight
leather jacket just running around the
school
so where should we go first
uh should we should we do the dancing
it's in the thumbnail right that's the
picture with you yes
i don't know
it's
it's something to get you excited my
oh wait i went the wrong way no wait i
didn't
it's this one
build me a profile
so
there is like this whole
mechanic of building
your robots and
getting different parts
there's also the sweet music
more really good music uh we'll do a
practice match because i actually am not
uh i don't have the right parts to to
win the the intermediate the inner
league match
we're trying to win the championship
so is this part of the whole like
if you want to advance this sub story
you got to get the parts to build the
right parts for the robot you do um
so that's the one thing this one kind of
like it does get a little where some of
them can kind of you could just kind of
keep going this one uh you feel you do
have to like grind out a little bit more
to get the right parts which is a bit of
a bummer
um but i do actually find it kind of fun
to do
all right let's try this one
so how good is your robot right now what
is it is it is a powerful one it's okay
it's so it's okay for these matches it's
it's nowhere i need better parts for the
main stuff but so basically uh this is a
like territory control minigame
and uh i'm controlling this robot and
you basically want to
grab these
bits
[Music]
and so either you want to have the most
points at the end or
join stole
uh
or you actually want to uh if you take
over their area you'll auto win which is
actually the the real strat uh it's way
easier to just like
try and take try go in and take them
over
so pro tip when you play this uh it took
me a minute to realize but it's like nah
that's the move that's that's actually
what you want to do
the builder is having a time
yeah my guys are just kind of
absolutely destroying them
oh he's so happy
i beat a bunch of high schoolers
oh and you get the the crafting stuff
for doing it yes yes so um
when you do the the little practice
matches
uh it'll straight up tell you here the
item drops you will get from that so you
can like uh prioritize um what you want
to get so they make it they make it fun
um and not too challenging
um but anyway that's the robot stuff
i like it
i quite like it
i love how all these these these rooms
have like
their own dedicated spaces for all yeah
you have to physically go to each room
uh which can get a little annoying after
a while but i do i do for the most part
like that about it um there's the
esports club here
which uh we've kind of beat the story
line but uh yeah they play virtual
fighter competitively
so you can play around a virtual fighter
uh maybe
maybe we'll pass on that for now for the
sake of showing other stuff uh because
it is it's just virtua fighter 5
um but i i really enjoy that one for the
um the the dialogue is really fun
uh
we also have the
uh photography club
uh that we're
i'm part way through on that one we
could do we could do a photography club
one
jordan
take take me on a journey
a great and wise master
former club president
of the photography club
former what's he doing around these
parts
were you doing hang around high school
kids
we still wearing the uniform
i think he just pushed the clothes
yeah he's still wearing his high school
uniform
yeah
it's like the way it fits
photography like those in kiwami 2
probably probably not
probably probably not like those ones
that's a different type of photography
incredible phenomenon
oh
[Laughter]
gives me big um
phoenix right energy sometimes on this
one
uh that's great i like that
he actually one of his big phrases he
says all the time is naruhodo which uh
was throwing me off because i've just
been playing a lot of greatness attorney
chronicles
and the uh main character's name is
naruhoto which is a
just a pun
very good pun
okay he's going to university next year
that makes sense yeah
examine the popularization of
photography the spread of uh
something something
yeah he's a photography nerd
the same dude
these these these ones these people are
weirdos they're they're kind of weird
her whole thing is she's like if i take
pictures of people doing evil deeds and
then show them the photo they'll see
themselves and see how bad they look and
then they'll feel bad and they'll repent
everything comes back to
our justice and judgment and it's true
judge yourself through these pictures
see that's the third game instead of
lost generally judgment yourself
there it is
final judgment
fine yeah
motorcycle gang
made in heaven that's the motorcycle
gang we're in
we're also in a motorcycle gang
of course
uh it just makes me think of claire
redfield's jacket
when i see it
to be fair
her old jacket a new one i don't think
that's it
yeah yeah
all right we gotta photograph the hot
rodders
good thing we're already in with them
i'm good
so what what are the
doing no good
uh yeah they're they're doing no good we
have to take photos of them
being
bikers
oh no
oh these guys aren't nearly as cool as
the biker gang i'm in
oh this isn't this isn't your students
this is a more rambunctious spider
okay so we got to make sure all the
citizens look annoyed in the frame
those people are about to get hit
this usually this these these take a
couple tries for me to get um
this includes everyone's faces
oh they're gonna come back around
on the other side
it'll it'll just make me kind of like
redo it
um
oh i see okay
so if you want everyone's faces
wouldn't you want to come from the other
side
yeah or oh no wait wait
take them away i need to take that max
you're in the you're in a good position
okay the position is right i just need
to be maximum
you got it third time's the chart
we got this we got this
okay
right here
raise camera
max zoom
yo there it is
boom look at that photo
perfect excellent
that's a lot of experience
nailed it
they made that very easy they ran right
into a giant group of people
uh pokemon things in like a dragon the
perverts the pervert pokemon oh yeah
if you had to catch if you had to
photograph them it'd be like pokemon
snap
oh
that that they're saving that for like a
dragon too
probably yeah yeah you gotta do that
huh
oh shoot
show him the picture
he's a first-year
they're getting wild out there
this is you
on a bike
sure the music is also set in the mood
so it's a lot of her just being like
don't you feel bad with this photo and
he's like no
i'm gonna i'm gonna kill you now
and then yoga has to beat them up
yeah
[Laughter]
yes
why does this always happen
just like bobbing up and down
always ends in fighting
really i feel like that's how it's gotta
go
i guess so yeah always resorts to
violence
asking is this game
oh yes
absolutely yeah
uh
always gonna wholeheartedly recommend
any
any rgg game
yeah but of course if you haven't played
the first judgment or any of the other
yakuza games uh i would recommend
starting there first before jumping on
this one
the throws in this disarming style are
very good
yeah i like this new snake snakes oh
yeah than this
you don't actually punch them you just
freak them out a little bit
yeah
that way they can get away with you
fighting high school too
except i still just beat the [ __ ] out of
him anyway yeah well you could do that
anyways
love the first judgment you're you're in
you know the first judgment
no reason not to pick this one up
no reason to be lost you have been found
by judgment too exactly
oh now she's gonna show the picture and
he's gonna be like oh no i'm so sorry
and it's not because of the picture it's
because
they're playing they're playing my
favorite track
uh
this is like the sunset bridge
equivalent of what persona i've had
i hope we get it here at once they have
a couple tracks in here that are
extremely persona
nice
[Music]
i think they they first introduced this
track back in uh back in zero and like
the substories and then i think they
were just like well
it's so perfect we have to put it in
every game forward
[Music]
i mean there's i mean there has to be
[Music]
i haven't played enough to be able to
say anything about it personally but
you just think about what uh what's the
story not being great
i i like the story i i think it's it's
it's mixed is what i would say um
if you've kind of like looked at reviews
and stuff i'd say it's very like hit or
miss like some people really really
liked it some people didn't like it i
kind of fall on this like in the middle
camp where i think there are things
about it that
are pretty flawed but overall um i'm
still having a very good time with it
granted i haven't finished it 100 but i
am like pretty far in um i still enjoy
it so i i think
i don't know i mean
it's hard to say because i think
everyone just kind of seems to have a
different reaction to it um
they they they really go for it and you
know
maybe they just kind of like
they don't hit it at every point well
the main thing i hear is uh the story in
the first judgment was a much more
personal one
this one is just kind of another case
for you to solve as a detective
very much so maybe that affects how
people see it um if you don't mind it
being less personal maybe you'll still
find things to like yeah yeah like
yagami has like less personal stakes in
in the story for sure um
so so i think i do think it's not as
strong as the originals hi
i don't think that helps you but
maybe maybe a little bit but i still
think like hey man like it's if you had
a good time with the last judgment it's
still worth playing it's still good you
know
yeah yo you'll still find stuff to like
you'll enjoy it probably yeah like the
story's still the story's still fun the
characters are still like yagaming and
kaito and all of them are like fantastic
and yeah you'll see where we get to play
as kaito later on um
that's why i got
i went with the digital ultimate edition
because i don't want that dlc exactly
yeah yeah and then all the side stuff
we've been showing off during this
stream today
quite excellent
there's always plenty to do in any rgg
game
i think the the bigger editions also
come with more school side stories
how do they wow yeah it would i think
it's uh
stuff for the side stories like you get
stuff for them you know
something like that yeah like i think
robotics parts um but i know that one of
the other things is that because they
added extra trophies for these i guess
because in the first game there were
like four different girls you could
romance and i think for this game three
of them are dlc and one is in the base
game which is kind of weird
yeah so there is like a menu that was
like
uh how many dates you've been on and it
was just like zero of one i was like
there's only one that's weird so that
makes sense
yeah they weirdly lock three of them
behind dlc
and there are dlc specific trophies
that's gonna be weird
uh
get the picture question mark so that's
what it was that's the second one was
so they did not they did not continue
can't see
it well i guess you know biker gangs
terrorizing people is no laughing matter
yeah
serious business
okay
it's time for dancing
ooh
get some uh
some
i'm excited for this because i've only
done the because there's a main quest
line dancing tutorial thing but i
haven't actually
done the day
uh dance practice
let's wrap it up
okay so i got it keep it real that's
what it says
i think i just unlocked the last song as
well so
should i do an older song or should i do
up to you i'm okay with you doing the
last one if you want to do it yeah what
are you guys
what are you guys feeling
[Music]
got this
that i can't i can't not look at yaga
being a fedora
well you could you can pick whatever
outfit you want
uh is there any that stick out to you
it's like just really really good uh
they're all really good
we'll do a couple why don't we do a
couple because yeah so you start with
the first we'll start with the first one
and then i won't do the third because
the third one has uh some choice moves
that uh
okay oh boy
uh
jeffrey is asking
it's a very good game i'd recommend it
even if you weren't thinking about
playing this one
uh
yeah play the first
[Music]
is the
what's the difference if you played on a
harder difficulty
anymore there's more um
they'll have a lot more like uh of like
the
double stuff where you're like oh like
the two of them will be paired together
for sure i mean like do you get anything
different for playing on our difficulty
no not really just more points there's a
separate difficulty scores associated
with each difficulty but as far as
progressing the dancing storyline you
can actually play it on any difficulty
you want
oh interesting cool
look at this boy
why don't you take a dmga for this
that'd be wild
it's their own music so i think we're
fine i think we're fine too
[Music]
oh let's just talk over it
that's right yoga is the number one tick
tock star
just kidding flex on these balls
well think about it
that'd be good advertising for the
detective agency to have like a
tick-tock account right and i would have
much power
[Music]
i love these camera movements like dudes
like the chance
this is wonderful
yeah
[Music]
that it's okay
all right play it on extra easy
extra easy is actually you can literally
just hit any button it's how they do it
okay
probably do this this one so i forgot
about this part
the you can basically interject it with
these different moves so you can be like
freestyle
or
some popping and locking
locking and
the yagami popping
be walking around popping d that's not
how that works and some breaking so uh
you guys got any uh
um go back to the popping
i do love that there are just breakdowns
of popping and or locking
oh that one's interesting the robot
i like popping c and d i think those are
really popping c in there
yeah
freestyles is like
yeah these are all great
i enjoy all of these it's
at that point what's happening there
we'll do that one
and then uh
give me breaking d
it's a new one it looks like you haven't
done it yet
[Music]
put together our own cool
dance routine
look at you perfect perfect perfect
that's awesome
i love it
i
i won't be keeping it real sure
yeah
oh they're all wearing it i didn't
realize everybody yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
wait why don't you get a cool hat
yagami's too
proud
oh here we go here he goes
[Music]
oh here we go break it
[Music]
no teeth
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
what excuse me wow alrighty there
what are you teaching the kids
[Music]
going
[Music]
oh
all right
i think we'll save the the other dances
i don't want to spoil everything
that's fair there's some uh
some dancing for you that's one of my
favorites it's it's uh
it's just so good
i love
ever since they revealed that i forget
what what they showed and i was like
yeah this is
this is perfect because it's like you
know every rgg game it's that mix of
like serious
drama than like these
okay what do we got left to show off uh
we should show off oh we should
definitely show off the girls bar and
the boxing gym for sure
yeah yeah yeah
i'm surprised high school has a girls
bar club
i think they ran out of clubs so they
were like um
it's like unrelated you're like oh
there's uh somebody there who knows
something about
a delinquent at the school uh so it's
not
it's not an actual
girl's bar
in this school
same with the boxing uh the boxing gym
yeah yeah yeah the boxing gym's got its
like own fighting mechanic to it uh
which is a lot of fun
so we want to go
head over to sunset bridge
hey it's the homeless camp from like a
dragon
you go in there is it closed though now
you can go in here there's a
there's a shopkeeper
who uh you can buy rare stuff from uh
using your sp points
um
cat food the important thing
oh yeah yeah oh hold on
while we're here
hang on these cats
uh i gotta remember uh
oh was it honey or baby
oh no
i'm gonna say honey because they're cut
the color of their their fur
okay we're gonna go with honey we think
it's honey
yes got it right cool
uh
we're gonna offer honey some food uh we
got some home style chicken cat food we
got some fresh tuna
cheese salmon
i have the cheese salmon oh fancy
the fanciest feast
and he gave me a scorpion
what
oh thank you thanks kitty
what
i
have so many questions that i'm just not
going to ask
ooh the boxing gym is right across the
street
i wonder if this boxing gym is in like a
dragon but you just can't enter
maybe yeah i always love going back and
looking like oh did they like see that
there because they're working on those
games at the same time
yeah
uh
let's see yes you get like a whole
separate
thing
the submarine straight
yeah you unlock more people to fight yep
all right we're gonna let's try this guy
it's a pretty muscular high schooler i'm
just gonna i know
yeah these are all like uh ex-cons who
have turned over a new leaf and found a
a positive outlet in boxing
that's good
would you love to see that positive
outlets are always always good
my money's on garcia
maybe he's the dragon of boxing gym
you've got like this is actually like a
proper boxing game you got like yeah
yeah yeah
yep you got stamina you got uh like your
straight hook and jab
uh you got your stamina meter you can
like block you can do like mid and high
so would you say i should get this or
ufc
2022 whatever they used to be i mean
does that game also let you skateboard
good point is there a is there a crime
drama in ufc 2022
surprised at this point some of those
little sports game story modes
but this game also has a story mode
within just for the boxing it's just oh
yeah
the stories and stories
it's like the matrix of
we stories some good hits
yeah
all right my money's on yagami again
i never doubted you
uh
i'm looking at the props on the side
there's no option to like
get below the belt or
grab or anything
no
it's probably for the better
yeah these are well we keep it very uh
get keep it very clean here
what's the ex good to do i mean
we're saving yeah i'll say i'll save it
for the next round if it
if he doesn't pass out but uh it
basically yeah just like you do more
damage and
can like hit faster
is
basically the uh the arena tournament
stuff that would be a regular
seems like
uh
yeah
i guess so because there is there is no
like arena tournament
um in this one
oh story we got story developments
this guy's like a former boxer who he
now works at like a uh uh collection
agency
so he's turning into a into a
scumbag
oh no
ah
oh no
i don't care
if only he believed in the heart of the
boxing
exactly it's okay i'm sure we'll beat
the [ __ ] out of him miss geography and
then he'll
turn over new leaf
yeah we'll get a photo of him and show
it right back
um
my grandfather's clubs have no fat
techniques
[Music]
but it does contain the unstoppable
green glove
[Music]
heroic sounding like
i love you
i love how there's like
little yugi who's like you know like a
more innocent child and it's the same
voice actor for the dub it does both
like yeah
i love it um
i've been re-watching the yu-gi-oh anime
just for nostalgia sake and it's been a
very fun ride oh hell yeah
but uh yeah you know what they should
add in this game though there should be
like a card game school club you
know board games and like card games and
stuff
yeah i need the i need the rgg version
of gwen
there you go
what if it was like the rgg version of
like yu-gi-oh and it's like when they
when he like kaiba loose as a duel it
was like you get to beat the [ __ ] out of
you now like yeah it's just like one
fist fight
forget the cards let's fight for real
some of the hp counters pop up
all right so we're gonna hang out at uh
oh y'all bar we're gonna go we're gonna
have girls bite
uh and we're gonna we're gonna chat up
some ladies
uh i do like to see the the progression
of how these mini games go from game to
game because they've they've changed a
lot yeah this one invokes a lot of like
the uh i would say it's like a
combination of the like hanging out with
the girls and the cowboy club in four
mixed with the um a little bit of the
telephone minigame from zero
okay uh also this is a really cute bar i
just want to say i'm uh i'm a big fan
uh so yeah so you can go hang out with
uh all the different girls um
there's also this guy memory son who's
uh he's just a really big fan of girls
bars and he wants everyone to know how
cool they are
uh oh cool well i i was just about to
say i think these are all male customers
ah a good drink
ah
let's see
i wonder if i've unlocked her because
because apparently also as part of it um
you will
as you hang out with each girl and like
sort of like build up their like
friendship meter you'll unlock a
substory with each of them as well
of course
sounds like it's it's got like a like a
greatest hits kind of combination of all
of the
all the different versions of it then
yeah i would say so
okay i really enjoyed what you did with
six so i feel like it's a good natural
progression
oh right there's that whole thing in six
like at that at that bar right and yeah
yeah oh
i like that one
yeah that was really good i like
accidentally discovered that like way
too late
like i just like for whatever reason i
never ran across like that exact street
corner
until like
the final two chapters so like curious
like running to the end to you know go
save everyone and then it was like
actually i gotta go stop in here to hang
out with all these people and i was like
oh no
how did i miss this
oh no i'm sorry that my beard has given
you goosebumps
uh i promise you i'm not a viking or a
youtuber even though we're on youtube
you're you're safe here speed runner i
promise
we're just hanging out of the girls bar
you know
having a good time
i don't actually know what a girls bar
is is it like
so
the way the game described it and kind
of looking it up it is
it's
a it's it's like a cabaret but the
difference is that the girls are always
behind the bar so you don't uh
you're not like directly sitting next to
them there's kind of like a separation
uh between between them um and the girls
have more power over it so like they the
girls kind of dictate who they talk to
uh you can't like request a girl at a
girl bar
at least that's the way the game
describes it i'm not sure how much that
translates to
how they actually function
no that that makes sense i was just
confused at first because there's like
all guy customers i was just like wait
but now i get it
yeah i like how this is set up so far
it's just the really good social stuff
mixed in with whatever else you got
going on
yeah we're getting her like whole story
oh we're hearing about her dad oh no
yeah
yeah
it'd be like that sometimes she's just
gotta you gotta open up a bit
that's part of the experience
[Music]
[Music]
this is the part in the stream where we
all get really into the story that's
happening and we forget
because that's what happened
when you stream a yakuza game yeah i'm
just like oh man
[Music]
it's something to do with the music and
the the camera angles it's the tragedy
yeah tell us more about yagami more
drinks
sure just purchase judgment for
playstation
all right
okay i see yes okay so you you
ultimately do you
date these girls or is it just
i don't think so let's see the heart
but i don't know if that's just so the
whole thing is you're trying to your
your main goal is to hit up emily
because she's the one who like knows
information um about the delinquent but
she won't talk to you
uh unless she's interested in you and
the only way to get her interested is to
basically become friends with all the
other three girls so if you do that then
emily will want to chat with you
but you also unlock side quests if if i
saw that correctly you locked the side
case by talking to her so like do you do
individual cases for each of the girls
okay i think so i think so
because i remember in the first game
that like heart meter when like you went
on dates with the girls it would like
fill up and then when you unlock the
next one you like went on the next date
yeah i didn't know if that works
correctly
okay
interesting
i sure have
oh you shot down yoga me it's like oh
oof i didn't even remember his name
oh
damn yoga me
guess i'll have to drink more
i guess i'll have to make this sub story
longer all right well uh i i want to
show off the actual mechanic of it so
why don't i go um
uh let me just get my drunk meter all
the way down real quick uh do that move
do that move
oh my not
oh i can't maybe
different stance yeah
no i just need to uh
oh i just need to fill my heat a little
bit
it's still so
good it's it's such a like a wild action
got him
oh
oh
yeah
that's a good ending
got a paper plate i'm no longer drunk
it all works out
because if you're too drunk they're like
you have to leave the bar now like you
can't have too many drinks
oh i think we're going to meet another
girl
oh interesting so it's like more get
added over
all right so you gotta pick the right
drink for her
uh each girl likes to go drink she likes
this one
[Music]
i can probably go for a dreamy berry
right about now
here i say noon 12 noon
it's it's night somewhere in the world
that's true
so then uh you'll play this mini game
where yagami gets really drunk and you
have to like
uh
spin sentences together
to make the right sentence
i love dragon rapper
oh wait it's called girls bite i thought
it was a girl's bar well it's like it's
a girl's bar but the bar's name is
girl's bite
got it okay
uh i never know what to make for dinner
every night so started living on my own
what kind of stuff do you normally eat
yagami
listen i'm no chef
i just eat instant noodles
in rice bro
okay that didn't
work but all the options were bad all of
them were leading to the same
weird thing i'm a weird man it's a weird
thing
oh okay
uh we drank a lot today y'all come
together to think up cocktails
have you taken a liking to the original
cocktails here
okay
um
i must say
this cocktail is
the best i've ever had
well thank goodness there was a there
was a
choice shouldn't sit down
it's like the telephone one from uh from
zero
where you're trying to like spin
together the right words
what kind of makes sense i like it
do you come to girls bars often
uh
not hell yeah much this bar is this
a special exception
hey hold on
those choices
yeah if you read go back and read some
of them
so we've had a trick on it
yeah if you pick them wrong do you just
leave and come back and try again yeah
yeah she'll be like you just won't get
much progress uh
at all and but you'll have you know
drinking and then you'll just gotta keep
keep trying
did that make sense yeah so uh you can
also play darts with them and that will
also get up your
stat as well
darts is a dangerous time
still i still kind of have
even though i did all right during
persona
uh
flashbacks of
being worried about not doing well in
darts
the thing about uh royal is that you can
unlock
like a open your third eye ability that
like slows down time and makes it like
very very easy um but yeah
this game like it's it's gyro right or
is it not gyro no the right stitch
it's the stick yeah
but it's also like it pushes against you
a little bit doesn't it
moves around
also this lag is killing me
i imagine
yeah
i see that we're we're getting a call to
wrap it up soonish how are we that makes
sense after this segment yeah yeah we
can do that
it's it's been enough time
i feel like i feel like we've done a
pretty good job showing off some of the
new stuff some of the crazy stuff yeah
oh yeah absolutely
and all wall avoiding spoilers
come on
it was close feels good
oh
ah
you made it in the orange
i guess that's not good enough by their
standards
nice there we go there we go
so you get the the screen that's all
that matters
yes
she's not very good
or maybe she's letting you in
could be
oh i hear the cabaret club music in the
background
yeah
i do like the repurposing of just
other game music or sega music
yeah
like
when you went to go and like go to the
gym
in six you'd hear like sonic oh six
music
okay i don't know yeah i don't know who
asked for that or who set that up but
that's great
nailed it
did she still win this i guess not right
or
i mean if i keep goofing up and i if i
don't hit like the exact zero at the end
um i don't think i lose immediately but
uh she could
theoretically win that way
yeah because the highest you can get any
one round is
because you get 57 by getting the triple
19. right no
the triple 20 yeah yeah 60.
so you can get uh you can get 180 right
yeah per round
oh
what oh because i'm at 4 i'm at 44.
oh
[Music]
that was stupid
i didn't even know
i was not paying attention at all oh my
god
it wasn't either
i was like that dude that's a nice shot
yeah
oh my god perfect
okay okay so
220's on the show
yeah i get 220's
or if you get a double and it's probably
too hard to hit that
oh
okay
what was that oh
a one it's a one
oh wow oh it was a one oh my god yeah
okay uh
okay yeah you might wanna aim right
there
oh
okay
okay
you got this where is the three
yeah i mean i still might win if she
because she kind of sucks but
now watch her just like completely
obliterate yours oh yeah this was her
secret
[Music]
oh she was playing me the whole time
oh
if she gets the ball you lose
oh no
that was almost disaster
that was an intense game oh
yeah look at that
well right then i think that is where
we're going to call it
this has been uh
our uh yakuza not yakuza i mean it's
like a dragon stream uh
yakuza like a detective
i'm like a detective i love it uh
thanks for joining us everyone hope you
had a good time hanging out with us
seeing some uh lots of minigames i had a
good time it was fun
i had a great time thanks for having me
yeah of course uh appreciate it and uh
yeah if you guys uh haven't already seen
it you should go check out our uh
review if you're still kind of curious
to hear more about the game it's a very
good review uh done by richard wakeling
um
uh he gave it a 7 out of 10 which i
think is a fair score but it's also
still
uh a very good game um
and that review uh is kept pretty
spoiler free as well i cut it myself uh
and i it's a i really try to make sure
oh thank you thank you gaming shots of
the popo was really nice oh appreciate
that yeah yeah
uh so anyway yeah go check that out and
uh yeah for more coverage of uh
all things yakuza rgg whatever video
games stay here to game spot guys we'll
catch you next time
you